the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to the 2022 summer
chess classic we're already in round
number seven here at the st louis chess
club and to bring you all of the action
we're grand masters alejandra ramirez
and christian carrillo christian
alejandro always a pleasure to be here
in the studio with you studio b casting
the games of the best chess players we
have here on st louis soil tell us about
these two tournaments that were casting
alejandro we have two different terms
for you guys group a and group b two
fill to the brim with strong
grandmasters and talent and we certainly
are bringing some exciting players
they're not quite the same field cup
they're not quite the us championship
but they're almost there and actually
some of these players they were there
they played the same leadership and
blitz we even have an olympic gold
medalist
at this tournament absolutely absolutely
now talk to me about the standings in
group a alejandro what do we have there
it's benjamin godura and that olympic
medal is yu yangyi that currently sit in
first place now remember that yuyani has
already played ray robson who had to
withdraw from the event and gledura has
not for therefore yu yang yi is down a
game that's three and a half out of six
for him instead of three and a half
sorry three and a half out of five zero
three and a half out of six third place
is sam savion and abhimanyu misha around
hakobian jonas bier and nicolodoro all
set in two and a half points meanwhile
grigorio parry having a little bit of a
rough tournament with two points elias
mirren in one and a half and as we
mentioned ray robson they could cover it
midway through the tournament and had to
withdraw and i have to say the b group
is quite combative as well we have
guillermo vasquez and jj ali marandi
sharing the leadership position with
four points apiece kamil dragoon mikhail
antipov and christopher yu only half a
point behind tied for the third position
tied for the sixth position we have the
chinese zhu zhang chao and john burke
student at webster university in eighth
place brandon jacobson who unfortunately
fell ill yesterday and had to withdraw
tight for the last position we have nico
checker and tigran harold union and how
about the tournament format alejandro
pretty straightforward we have two
player uh 210 player ron robbins down to
nine both of them unfortunately
classical time control for you nine
minutes 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game and a 30 second increment all
throughout the schedule is easy we have
one round a day here in this tournament
we only have three rounds left 1pm is
the start time for every single round
our commentary starts at 3 30 goes on
for 90 minutes and remember that we have
a big exception on friday as we might
have playoffs and if necessary we will
have those at 5 p.m to accommodate them
we will be starting uh the last round
two hours early as well as our broadcast
will be starting at 1 30 p.m on friday
and also if you do want to join the
conversation you can reach us on social
media we are quite active there you can
reach us at
summer chess classic on twitter also
you're probably watching this show
either on youtube or on twitch or
ushchamps.com
it is very important we have this
interesting mission to support chess
from the foundation up for every 75
dollar that you donate in the form of
bits subscriptions and so on on twitch
one child will get a full semester of
chess coaching tell us about that
alejandro absolutely we have uh
grand masters here at this lewis chess
club that help not only in what's elite
chess but also scholastic chess and
promoting talented youth here in america
we have camps we have select chess being
taught by veins we have grand masters
and residents that come and teach some
of this talent to you so this really
does go a long way the same with chess
club does everything from very beginner
chess to absolutely elite and everything
in between so that being said let's take
a look at the pairings in group a what
do we have for you today it is group a
four game sam savion is playing elias
miriam young jonas bier is playing a
crucial game against benjamin ladura
adam jacobian is playing against uh
grigori o'byrne and the matchup of the
day without a doubt will be between the
youngster abimanu misha who has really
impressed so far here in st louis not
just in this tournament but in the
previous
classic in the spring classic that he
won convincingly earning his right to
play here in the a group he's done
amazing he's on a plus one score
i guess incredibly strong opposition uh
he got a little bit lucky in a couple of
games but he could have actually
progressed absolutely even further and
some others meanwhile young yi has been
having a great tournament you could only
really say that he was in severe
pressure in the first round in the first
round against her maybe against
also some problems but besides that he's
had a pretty smooth sailing he's
currently on plus two and trying to wrap
up this tournament this will be a huge
round between them no absolutely he is
definitely showing that he is the top
dog in this event with the level of play
with the class of his chess it just
feels like
as of right now he is the best chess
player in this tournament and as we uh
can see abi manu is right now pondering
his next decision actually queen to b7
was met by knight to east defending that
rook this is not actually their game
this is the uh
yeah as you can see oh yes as you can
see from the from the position
absolutely i think uh unfortunately our
transmission is wrong at the actual game
position right now it looks much more
troublish it is a it is a lot more
drawish why up a pawn in the position
that we see if you can count them up
it's difficult from this angle no no
there's no pawn up no equal pawns i'm on
the wrong game too
equal pawns actually this game is dead
that that dead because there are no
extra puns for anybody yep this one
e3 is going to come on the board
followed by rook takes d5
we are going
to have um
yeah and as we will um get to see my
screen in just a second and get to the
analysis there's nothing to analyze here
three versus three in a rook end game
these guys will just rush towards a draw
another great result for abimagi who
keeps impressing in this tournament
unfortunately we didn't get to catch
much of this game yep but it is clear
that he belongs oh alarms in this
tournament he belongs fighting for the
first places in this event he's he's
shown great resilience
and great preparation i'm nothing short
of impressed no absolutely and as we can
see the game right now
on the board is a dead draw we're going
to see some sort of uh
rook d8 followed by king h7 rook d7 king
ga they're going to find a professional
way to finish this game and um in fact
um let's talk about the b group as well
because we have two groups uh in this
event tell us a bit about the b group
the big group is full of collegiate
players it's a very
strong affair as well uh we already have
some results today camilo dragoon has
drawn against guillermo vazquez and
meanwhile brandon jacobson remembered
that he did feel uh feel sick so he had
to withdraw from the tournament uh he
loses by four feet against john burke
doesn't change the rating but does give
a full point to the standings of john
burke and the other matchups nico check
is playing into groundhog
this is a matchup between two players
that have a really tough tournament so
struggling so far absolutely misha and
deepav is playing against christopher
you and uh the matchup of the day
without a doubt is going to be this one
between
chao and jj alimorandi jj's had a great
tournament actually uh had a one
position technically one position
yesterday against camille dragoon was
unable to convert uh the rokan game
which was still very very tricky uh and
currently he is trying to wrap up
what would be his first uh victory in a
spring classic or oh sorry in a classic
tournament he's played a few of these
but never won one no absolutely and
actually let's take a look at that game
because it is indeed quite interesting
once again we see
jj in an end game we've seen him
yesterday in an end game as well
the better side of an end game
unfortunately for him he was unable to
convert what we thought was quite a
significant advantage but right now with
the black pieces i have to say i do like
the activity of his pieces once again
and this is one thing about jj he always
loves to have his pieces active almost
never i see him in a passive position
would you um say that's a good read
alejandro i would say that the reason
you don't see it very often is because
the moment that he gets into a passive
position five minutes
later
he really really doesn't play those
positions well he always fights for the
initiative like to play his kind of in
balanced positions
kind of curious at what's going on uh
unfortunately we are doing this
commentary without engines and we are
doing our best to try to understand
positions i have to confess something i
was too late at turning off my engine
here
so
before we get into that let's just take
a peek at the time situation between the
two players one minute for zuzia and
ciao and 47 minutes at move 27 for
alimorandi that is a big discrepancy
between the players and that's still
telling because it's a very sharp
position
i was just trying to get to the core of
it it's not easy to do so um
black structure is actually much
superior to white sure uh the spawns on
the h file are pretty garbage yeah
uh but it is two bishops
uh it is an open file for the rook you
have to prefer black
you just have to there's no way that
black is uh worse in this position the
question is how much
well let's make the easiest move in the
position
maybe
yeah sure let's even though i kind of
want to play the move b4 now the idea of
this move b4 is that i'm looking at this
knight and i want to get it involved
into the game and vif4 would probably be
the best avenue now the problem is this
bishop is controlling so i'm going to
use my b pawn as a decoy right i'm going
to play the move b4 i can take on a2 but
then you will use this light square
bishop to take on b5 what i want to do
is play the move b4
provoke you perhaps to go bishop to d6
keep an eye on this pawn on b4 take take
and now at least i have the extra option
of finally involving my knight in play
with knight to f4
what do we think about this one i really
like this position at the end especially
with the threats
of bishop h3o
it is opposite color uh bishops in that
position but king king is too weak the
activity the king and and when we have
that for example let's just put a few
moves on the board knight way through
you probably have to take otherwise yeah
it's coming uh take on h3 and how do you
defend against rook to g2 yeah it's not
a deadly threat but it defines your
position because you're you're
permanently worried about background
checkmate exactly it's hard to get that
king into the game try to get some sort
of counter chances good luck with that
i'll give you a check and then i'm going
to go here now i have a big threat check
mating threat you have to go back and i
have time to do whatever i want i have
time to play b5 i had time to take on d
for whatever i want in the position
absolutely i agree with your question
here the activity would be too much i
think that b4 would be an interesting
move uh the only thing i would like to
calculate is hawaii because i hate
bishop d6 for me is b4 rookie 2. it
looks risky because i allow rook b1
but i don't see another way to do this
no this is a move but what if i just
take take and then bishop to b1 oh here
i'll
go bishop to uh yes day six and we get
into this position
because every time that you take my
light square bishop with your knight you
should give a draw it will be a draw
without the rooks and with the king
being so
it's just fine
i think actually it's not even worse
absolutely and that's exactly why it
seems like alimorand decided to go
knight to f6 now he's looking at the
same things right he's looking at a way
to involve the knight into play now
where is he going with this knight is
the question that is a
bit of a mystery for me because the
knight is already controlled by this
pawn on f3
and by black's own pawn on d5 correct
right if this pawn didn't exist you can
imagine the knight goes to d5 hops
around
but with the pawn on f3 and the pawn on
d5 i'm not really sure
you you do control the e8 square but
that wasn't a big threat it wasn't a
threat at all for for black yeah
yo said i don't see the point of this
move i'll play a3 defend my pawn once
and for all also prevent prevent before
well he has to make him move faster he
did
a3 all right
challenges jj to explain his last move
definitely an advantage for black
i have a feeling it's not that big no i
i'm a bit puzzled by this move now she's
very possible
as well trying to understand why he
okay so
maybe he was afraid of ideas such as
rook to e5 is
then you just simply go
yeah on a terrible day i go g6 okay so
let's say b4 root to e5
but
it's hard to believe this kind of moves
work for bla for for white right you go
g6 yeah and it takes point okay i can
even take on a2 i yeah rook b1 king f2
may be not so clear but i'll take on a2
but then i'll give you a check
i don't care i'll go king h7
my king is pretty safe bishop e5 will
always be mad with f6
as long as my knight is on h5 and you it
will always be on h5 right i'm not
really worried about getting mated
yeah and this pawn is actually going
down the board pretty quickly yeah this
bishop's useless so i have to go here
but now you have
yeah rook c2 i start trying to win yeah
trying away maybe just winning
yeah this bishop f4 5 is nicely
protecting uh this square d7 for the
rook because if i would be able to
involve my work into the attack with
rook to d7 getting more active i would
have a much better position not possible
um i agree all right a3 knight to f6 a
puzzling decision we have to say but we
do have a lot of games still pending so
let's take a look at what else is
actually let's jump to the a group and
check out the uh the games we've seen
the game of the day abby money versus
you young e not much what's happening
yeah nothing at all now what's happening
in this one between uh aram hacobian who
right now is two pawns up against grisha
of parin
two points up that's that's a lot of
pawns now
there's an obvious threat rook takes f2
and there's an obvious plan behind it
black is just trying to stay active yeah
at this point he sacrificed a couple of
pawns he said okay
if you do manage to stabilize the
position as white you're probably going
to be crushing me
but do you have time to stabilize the
position
and the question is a very pertinent one
because came to g first of all f4
doesn't work because of bishop to f1 and
you just lose a piece you lose a piece
instantaneously taking advantage of the
pin you can defend with king to g1 but
then i think repetition is coming yeah
and and let's point out that they
already repeated once aram is i have
okay aram is below on the clock so it
makes sense for him to repeat a couple
times get those 30 seconds get closer to
move 40. so he's repeating in a couple
of versions with the pawn on a2 and the
bishop on b5 and with the pawn on a4 and
the bishop on c4 clever boy i like this
practicality of repeating the moves more
than once gaining that time he knows
that he is ahead yes in the material
account he can always get that draw but
he is being very careful to add time to
himself and get closer to that move
forward i like this uh
but you see this pawn on g5 or white and
i'm really curious how that happened
because usually it's a very teaching
moment um whenever we see this
g5 coming on the board wow g5
yeah when g5 was played right
that was a while ago actually that was a
while ago and i'm not sure it was very
necessary you usually see it play out in
the end game already not with the queens
on the board
quite interesting now g5 of course
making a loof
freeing up
the rook on the eighth rank you don't
have to worry that much about any sort
of checkmating threats on the back ranks
so g5 queen to a5 bishop to e2 defending
the queen right now perhaps this was
actually
more or less all calculated
i'm actually looking at how much did oh
he spent a lot of time on g5 it's kind
of a weird move yeah 20 minutes
it feels so unnecessary was white really
threatening that much
i mean i get it i get it a7 is hanging
yeah
it's an unpleasant position
yeah perhaps it wasn't as easy as i
thought it was at the beginning no it's
an unpleasant position the the more i
look at it
the more pressure white seems to be
piling up right now but actually
i'm a little curious now that i see that
g5 was played sure
the more i'm trying to understand this
position g5 and welcome everybody that
just joined us i think we had a raid so
welcome everybody excellent welcome
raiders uh g5
can't i go queen e7
does that threaten anything i'm
threatening rook8d1
rook a to d1
that's
what no okay so rook 81 now
all right
and i just want to play rook d8 but does
that finish me off no but but if you
take it so it takes first of all only
has one thread quinnish to made right
right so do i made you probably not root
data how the feeling does not make you
i don't know if i have to take first but
let's assume i will
the national check is forced
and now the question is where do i hide
f6 or g6 f6 it does seem like you have
this
annoying check so let's start
on g6 followed by h6
it might just be a draw right and
perhaps just a draw yeah not only that
queen to h2 is coming but if you do try
to stabilize position like this there's
another checklist i'll try to maybe
stabilize before that f takes g3 instead
of uh rook d8 and keep the tension
so all the way down to this position now
just simply pick up the part pick up the
pawn i feel you're a bit stuck as black
maybe it's not the end of the world
maybe i am overestimating white's
chances oh i don't think i am so this is
um
this is a critical move in the position
it's one of the critical moves for sure
i have rooked the eight uh you cannot
take so you have to go there queen f8 is
still playable and let's just show why
you cannot take because you take with
the queen and then you take the look and
um
by the way this is still narrow ah yeah
it is over because you do have queen
queen d for you yeah
otherwise there are some perpetuals
around here
but okay so
i'm not going to take on the aww okay so
check on f8
it's cooking i'll do the same when
you're working g6 king to h6 try to get
rid of your checks maybe i'm not getting
to you
maybe i am not getting to you
and why i said it's critical this rook
to b1 is because it creates a very
imposing threat
fascinating game uh i don't think
that what happened in the game was fully
equalizing for black but oh definitely
let's try to figure out what's going on
right now because this was a long time
ago
right all the way towards the end uh by
the way aram still
thinking oh by the way he's played a5
finally finally he's going for it so is
jettisoning the pawn on f2 there was no
way to hold it i don't think black has a
choice
pick it up you have to pick it up if you
don't pick up this pawn then your last
moves didn't make any sense i mean i
actually played king g7 but i don't get
no i don't get the idea of black's play
no so pick it up yeah you pick up the
punk so kj's rook f2 doesn't have an
immediate thread but
it also challenges white to find a move
right it's it's difficult to say whether
you would categorize uh bishop f1 right
throughout i wouldn't because the bishop
my g2 is such
garbage but at the same time i'm cutting
off your king so if we go into this line
you're saying this might just be a draw
anyway yes and quite an easy draw
actually for black because i get very
quickly to g6 never i don't know if you
guarantee that yeah check here and i do
i do hide my polaron a7 and the idea of
these setups
is that it controls the king the king on
g7 is basically bound because the moment
that you move the king somewhere that i
can give a check to i pick up your rook
oh that's so this might be lost i'm not
guarantee let's see if you get in time
because i'm going to try to set up a
blow kick a blockade but i see that you
have this idea also now yeah and you
might actually get zuzan which is funny
no i don't think so how do you how do
you do it
i have to have a penetration square
right yeah
so
sago king this is my idea i'm going to
put the point on c4 but let me get a
king one here can you one this is my
point of this look zone can you want it
here that's okay
okay go forward
and you'll lose this eventually right
so i can also i can also go through h3
if you want to take on c3 with check
you go via h3 i go that way yeah if you
really want to if i really wanted to
huh so you might actually get in in a
suzwang situation and this might
actually be very relevant because aram
just played a6
oh my goodness so he is inviting bishop
f1 he's saying he's going for it he's
saying do you believe in your chances on
that end game oh that's that's very
serious actually that's actually very
serious because bishop f1 king jion is
absolutely forced you're not on time to
play rook a8 yes
not on time because this is the check
you don't attack it up yeah and then i
uh you don't do anything about blocks
just winning it's an extra piece so the
main question comes here on the move
uh
rookie two right away right it's it's
it's a big moment right now yeah i think
this is lost i think the same game is
lost rook a checking g7 a7 i do not see
a defense if i go all the way to e5
there's no way that you hold on the end
game because i'll pick up c5 somehow
yeah yeah i you always get me in in sus1
yeah i don't have any moves you just go
h6 you pick it up and once again i mean
let's use one yeah
he's not going for bishop f1 no i don't
think he can i don't think he can he
goes for rook a2 uh immediately targets
this pawn and of course he's going to go
check king g7 and a7 and now the idea is
that on bishop f1
i think he just goes rook somewhere i
just don't know where the rogue goes
rook
b8 let's say right or c c a whatever and
the point is that if you play rook takes
g2 check i go but then i pick it up um
but take take and i take e4 at the end
[Music]
not so easy to win the same game just
yet huh this might be what they're going
for by the way because this might be the
one is on a7 the phone is on a7 and i
don't see anything else that will block
your really well actually is there
something else black can do here because
i don't have to play bishop f1 you don't
have an immediate threat that's black as
white because
e5 is going to be met by bishop to d5
you would love to open up this bishop
obviously take on c6 uh unfortunately
you cannot do that
so
let's say i is black play e5 what do you
play
good point good point
and if you go here
i don't know
you know what let's let's go here let's
go on this side i'll give you a check
perfect and
then i'll give you a check and you go to
e3 right sure
and i cannot take on g2
i mean i kind of can but don't really
want to but you probably don't want to i
mean and i think even rook b8 is better
than rg8
this
yeah the same game is winning
yes yes most likely winning yeah there's
just too many points you might as well
get this a main game without the pawn on
e4
and the pawn on e6 yeah yeah which is
much more stable
um
yeah no wow what uh by the way e5 is on
the board if i'm on the board okay yeah
e5 hmm
well
but there's always going to be some zeus
wrongs here
nevertheless with a bishop on the board
it's much more difficult to get this
king you're involved in in play i also
have difficulties finding a way
for this bishop on g2 to join the fray
does this maybe there's no immediate
zugzwan's
and by the way they're playing allah
temple right now so he calculated this
move a5 he spent a lot of time and i
know he's just blitzing out the most we
said by the way yes just pointing that
out not bad
all right so rook to a1 king to f2 rook
to a two yeah perhaps this check is kind
of silly though
no he's he's not going for it he's going
for a bishop to e6
guarding this uh bishop to h3 idea but
now i wasn't sure about getting f1 to
the bishop to the
by the word where after
i i don't know
so you go to f1 but we're after i was
going to put it on e2 it's going to make
it that's going to help me make a bridge
you know what let's say i just do like
this
check or rook a3 doesn't matter no it
doesn't matter because i don't want to
play e3 here
so bishop to f1 yeah
they're following r they're listening
they're listening right now but how does
this hold for black
let's say that i eventually got my
bishop to say like b1
like i play bishop d3 i just want to go
with a very direct point all right i'm
going to put the pawn on c5 when you put
up on c5 i'll take advantage of that and
put my bishop on b5
that's fine keep going where do you want
to go
um
let's just hide it for now can you e3 i
don't know
okay
all right you are taking that i will
take it if you allow me to all right so
let's go let's put the king all the way
down on
b1 or something like that
yeah let's get to this position
all right
let's defend the stupid pawn c4
finally you play c4 yeah
now at this particular moment you cannot
take on g3 you cannot move your king and
you cannot move your pawn such a weird
position you can only really move your
bishop or your rook and your bishop is
pretty limited all right let's
all right i'll continue sit around
i'll continue uh king b2
okay
okay five finally
i have to move this rook away
this is about as much as i can get right
i think so i i don't see the follow up
there there has to be one
they're following exactly exactly what
we're saying
yeah so all the way after bishop e6
bishop one rook to a one word i feel
this is breakable let's go back to that
okay yeah bishop c6
this is the position that's a bishop c6
okay
like bishop d5
that's very beautiful
and then what that's a good question
yeah
and then
what
finally they deviated they did our
variation yes so after king to f2 he
played the move rook to a to another to
a3 okay slight difference but not a big
one yes they might still be going for
the same kind of stuff
it's
it's almost forced i it looks like it
right right so bishop to g4
it's uh it's a very intriguing end game
i have to say i i don't think i've seen
this exact configuration before
it's uh it's an interesting blockade you
don't see it often
yeah not very often i'm trying to
penetrate with my king but i just don't
seem to be able to do it
because imagine going all the way back
no but with your king to h2 and trying
to take away this diagonal from my
bishop let's say with a bishop back to
h3 i will give you a check at that point
right and that's not possible
and if you don't have this diagonal then
how do you penetrate with the king
yeah maybe maybe at some point i have to
go to for like a rook and game but
that's the thing
you would love to play rook c8 i could
play bishop beside bishop c8 in some
variations
with some kind of care right your bishop
needs to be on g4 blah blah blah go here
so if you go bishop c i pick up the pawn
you have to defend it first i have to
play like king b3 let's say yeah no be
careful i was fighting c3
so you so this is just winning
can i pick up the rook
so you don't have to be careful okay
so nice thing about the position most of
the checks were for white actually
probably king a4 here is better right
even better probably yeah yeah
um
all right so i'm not gonna fall for it
i'm gonna go rook a1
let's say i got bishop c8 here
does seem like i'm actually no no no i'm
not forced because once you take on e6
and then you're going to go to c8 yep
think of the rook engines are lost if i
pick up c5 right i think they are i
think they are the king is too far away
and i can always cut it with rook d5
which is the main problem they're very
concerning at least yeah they're not
completely losing they're very
concerning but i think they're
completely losing oh this is uh
this is a long but
long but relevant type of idea right
because you're trying to figure out how
to break
blacks blockade they're currently
sitting tight on the a file yeah uh
blockading the spawn on a7 from movie
because the rook is stuck on a defending
end so the moment i can actually defend
the spawn or or remove my work from my
aid i'm winning it's just one one small
step that's very difficult to achieve
we're trying to find a way to either
zuzong the bishop or suggest the rook
get away uh this pawn on a7
to move and by the way uh breaking news
we do have a result the first result in
group a the game of the day mishra
versus you young he has finished in a
draw that's awesome
now
we've been mesmerized by this end game
and i'm sure we'll come back to it in
just a second let's go through the rest
of the games in group a beer versus
gledura this announced uh itself as
a big contender game of the day oh my
god what's going on here
because these players are just so
talented uh both of them very combative
both of them want to make a splash in
this event this is going to be a lot of
checks
that's one
and that's probably the second one
hi but you know what's funny actually i
can just play queen c4 here
it continues yeah that's a lot of bonds
who knows how this endgame are i think
we know yeah it's probably why it's
definitely white this knight doesn't
even have a good square yeah i'm coming
to pick up your pawns and i only have
one on this side yeah if 96 t4 was legal
in this position i think we would say
that i don't know who's better
but
the knight is just stuck completely
right but that's not how pieces move
that's not that's not how pieces move so
black has just lost yeah so we're going
into this but king f3 is relevant now
the black is by no means forced to go
into the same game right you could play
something like queen d5 yeah yeah that's
a that's a good point but now i can go
king g3 and knight f4 ah beautiful
that's beautiful and i think this is
over that's over right because you take
i go here and that's it that's it that
picks up the queen and that's an extra
three pawns so after a queen you
actually don't have any other squares
it's okay i am running mate on g7 as
well as on e8 so this is over i don't
see a defense i don't see an angle in
which you can defend uh the spawn on g7
no not only that but queen to e8 is also
coming on the board so i mean there's
too many threats
yeah this one is a winning endgame
knight f4 is beautiful so queen d5
will eliminate it after king to
aftermath but if you don't have queen
defense the only move i mean queen c6 is
just a worse version of the same thing
this might be just uh completely losing
somewhere yeah yeah it might be over i'm
missing anything beer might be taking
this one wow
to the bank
queen takes e6 i mean let's let's no no
there's not there's no mystery here
there is no mystery there's no
illuminati
this knight is just garbage conspiracy
theory hot garbage all right
all right this is
i mean this is like you don't have to
calculate it i wouldn't know what the
assessment is if the king was on e7 yes
i wouldn't be sure right and i would
take white but maybe still white is
winning with the king on h8 and i forget
about it it's kind of what aram said
here with this interview precisely in
his game against beer
at this point you don't have to
calculate oh yeah you just understand
yeah
you don't have to calculate yeah yeah
king to f3 um
he's going to think about it he's going
to make sure that he's not missing
anything okay look at the body language
actually yeah they they look look at
benjamin benjamin is not happy he's not
a happy camper he sees this move knight
to f4
he understand that his position right
now
is busted oh yeah he knows he's a strong
player
benjamin is an incredibly talented
player well over 2650 has beaten amazing
players he actually beat a nand oh yeah
like he was still a talented youth also
at the olympia he uh almost always does
well um i remember he
oh yeah he scored quite a significant
amount of points in the last olympiad if
i'm not mistaken even maybe got a medal
or something along those lines i i think
we'll be playing for hungary in the next
olympics as well yes yes yes i i don't
see any reasons not to yeah he's going
through the six he's going for the sad
end game yeah the problem is queen d5
knight king
is resignation this is also resignation
yeah i think so
at least we keep going for a little bit
and queries x is the cleanest
but uh you can also consider 28. yeah
but then queen ga and i think it's the
same thing i think i think queen takes
c6 slightly cleaner
it just feels like queen take c6 yeah
and he's going for it knight to g5
yeah going straight into this line well
what an impressive performance for beer
let me try to remember what his
tournament results are he lost to adam
but he started early with a victory
right against iodoru
he's at least on
50
and he might be going to plus one with
this one i had the impression that he's
already on plus one but perhaps if only
we had the standings if only our
producers had a graphic with the
standings producers
why standings i don't think we have the
standings right now alejandro
i don't think they're even listening to
us unfortunately
so
looking for them
you don't expect the producers to listen
to ask i wanna know that sometimes it
happens you know sometimes i get
pleasantly surprised
until the producers are listening there
you go wow well that's actually a huge
score because jonas br is currently on
two and a half points remember that last
round he actually played quote unquote
ray robson this doesn't get any points
for it
is therefore on 50
will be going
on to um
plus one three and a half points
catching benjamin glendora no absolutely
not
this actually wow so after this round
it the way things are going right is
saving still playing savion is still
playing every single game outside of
mishra versus you young he is still up
so measures on three and a half union
yields on four
which is kind of amazing
um
benjamin will stay on three and a half
jonas catches him at three and a half
and potentially
potentially aram hakobian
with his extra pawn we don't we don't
know that one yet potentially iran will
also be joining the freon plus one
yeah no that's a big game uh that end
game between hacobian and oparin we will
keep an eye on that one for sure for a
very long time and let's take a look at
what's happening because you actually
were mentioning this game between
sam savion and elias mirin now this is a
big chance for sam savion to get a
victory in this one he's playing one of
the lower rated players in the event
sounds like 26 or 27 plus i mean you
have to make a splash in this one
especially with the white pieces and we
have a very intriguing position two
bishops obvious compensation actually
there's there's no extra there's no
extra fun yeah no compensation forget
about i'm starting to wonder if what's
better at all
i mean this is the bishop on d5 is a
monster the bishop on d5 is huge and
you could potentially at some point
think about sacrificing an exchange you
do have the option of playing the move
c4 kicking the bishop away
also you have your own trumps in the
position as white that square e5 is a
beautiful square for either the bishop
or the knight so right now this is the
dynamic
that we're trying to assess in the
position the bishop on d5 a tremendous
piece but potentially a peace landing in
the central e5 square for white as well
could potentially destabilize the
assessment of this position and i'm also
keeping an eye on the clock 13 minutes
for sam savion and only 10 minutes for
elias mirin with 10 more moves to go but
before we get into the analysis of this
position we do have a special guest
abhimanyo mishra abi welcome back to st
louis right now you're in group a uh
only a couple of months ago in group b
you dominated group b and now you're in
group a tell us how you feel about that
it feels amazing that group event was of
course very tough and winning that in
such a dominating way felt amazing after
that i had some i had another success at
reykjavik open
i got another 10 points i came second i
tied for a second there and yeah now
playing in group a and playing at this
level is it feels amazing like every
game like even though i was losing
against vra i was able to hold
everything absolutely no everything is
tying up together quite nicely now it's
more or less a shock a chest shock when
you play against this type of strong
2700 players for the first time but
you've also played against them quite a
lot online in the meltwater chess
championship tell us a bit about that
experience that was an amazing
experience where i got to play many of
the world's top 15. i was i was i played
against carlson my maniaro ding
and many others gary uh
how important is that experience for you
that was very important as it
as i'm not shocked like not i'm not
entirely shocked anymore i'm playing
against such strong players and i i
understand that they also have their
limits as such it's not like they can
see absolutely everything of course they
come very close to that but it's not
i i i understood that i can also see
things close to them everybody's human
after all and uh you play this
tournament in spectacular fashion i have
to say you haven't lost a single game so
far plus one a very respectable result
how would you assess your performance up
to this point are you content with it
yeah this is an amazing tournament for
me every game every game is a challenge
against against such strong players of
course i i still need to work on a lot
of things
many of you a few of the games i got
into losing positions or like worse
positions but i missed i managed to
defend them and yeah i think this is the
difference between like 26 and say 2700
the way how the how uh the person
defends the higher the more the higher
you go up the more the better they
defend like for example in melt water i
was winning i was completely winning
against the tingler end like plus 4.5
but he found some way and he tricked me
and in the end i lost
so
i think it's everything it's about
defense at above this level absolutely
now you're around 25 40
you obviously have a target on your back
in terms of rating do you enjoy this
position it might not last for a very
long time yeah i mean this
my target is to reach 2600 in another
few months and yeah it's looking very
great i'm getting like 15 points already
in this tournament absolutely no i mean
it's probably not going to last for a
very long time you're going to be at the
same level in just a second now talk to
me about this game between yourself and
one of the more established players in
the field you young he's been a top
elite level player for a very long time
yeah this was this was the game i was
looking
looking forward to the most at from the
start of the tournament and
in the opening i was a bit uh the ctx d4
i didn't really know but so i just tried
to like play natural moves and
hold the game c takes d4 yeah like 96
bishop g2 bishop c5 c3 i mean the reason
why i played c3 is if you go b3 there's
queen b6 ideas
and if you go knight c6 bc6 i don't want
to strengthen his center like oh sorry
like instead of bishop e3 but yeah it
probably doesn't make a difference take
on b3 uh take on e3 first yeah you can
take on e3
take
maybe yeah let's go some queen e2 but
still yeah this is nothing we take c3
even here
take queen two
probably is better who has the white
black who has the advantage yeah um
you play the move c3 knight to f6 castle
castle bishop to e3 and we got into i
mean this doesn't seem like i had any
advantage of the opening and i it felt
like i think i had to be precise in
order to hold the balance like 94 i have
to play cd4 because bishop b4 he has
bishop d4
cb4 queen b6 it's still kind of
unpleasant now your pieces become a bit
awkward like knight 3 bishop 5 a5
yeah
this
knight is not ideally placed on b3 by no
means and you took with the pawn you
mentioned that you had to stay precise
you felt
like you uh
instead of b4 for example if i trade the
knights on e6
rook to c6 i mean this kind of position
it looks pretty equal but it's really
boring objectively it's equal but yeah
it seems it's a bit unpleasant rookie
four queen f6 somewhere he'll play like
deforest always rookie a g6 h5 yeah no
it's uh quite um against such a strong
technician like you yankee it's there's
always a chance of losing this kind of
position absolutely you had to uh
try the very narrow path and you play
the move b4 take on c5 take with the b
pawn were you concerned at all about you
know the side fischer games or any of
that nature this knight versus bishop
situation yes a bit but i mean the thing
is if the pawns if he was able to get
the knight versus bishop ending it's
probably still holding i mean it's not
too big you've analyzed that yeah with
the seal yeah and i mean v6 i mean the
queen side pawns are disappearing and i
wasn't worried about like a four versus
four on the king side yeah as long as
king doesn't reach like say c4 c4 yes
yes absolutely take a4 i just wanted to
allow i just i didn't want to allow b5
somewhere because somewhere 97 can
defend that
queen to b3 and you kept everything
quite compact in the position rook c1
forces knight b5 and now it's just
finally just a draw um
great result for you abby monu now who
do you have tomorrow tomorrow if i leave
miriam he's also a very very strong
grandmaster he's played he's been many
of the top players
and yeah i'm looking forward to the game
actually my best excellent uh
championship rounds as we call them here
in st louis go get your rest and we'll
see you tomorrow thank you
what an uh impressive young ladab
emanuel mishra only 13 years of age and
such a strong presence
in the world of chess and let's get back
to this endgame the end game between
hacobian and grisha oparin because
as we did expect a lot of things have
happened a lot of moves have been played
and uh it does seem like white is still
trying to find that elusive way of
breaking through
black's defense um alejandro welcome
back
well thank you
um
not a clear way in right
great interview
i'm very impressed not only by his
maturity on the board but also his
maturity off the board oh yeah of course
we're very a down to earth kid and i am
really looking forward to what he has to
bring
in the next few years no no absolutely
all right let's take let's take a look
at this one now i don't know give me one
second now
i'm worried about the same game first of
all i'll tell you that i'm worried about
this end game a little bit and i want to
go back
a few moves
before at this point we were worried
with bishop to um f1
f1 why didn't we like this move king g1
king g1 and um
what was the move that we
no it didn't like no no no no no no no no it was rook
somewhere now rook somewhere yes
yes
wasn't this easier
i wasn't sure i was thinking about that
earlier and i wasn't really sure because
so i do go to g6 right no i'll get you
for it
i think g4 is kind of key don't play
this don't play that move don't play
this move oh that's such a visual
checkmate it's a funny channel um
okay so let's say i exchange one more
pawn yeah okay i do have to take i think
at this point and the eg3 king to g3
let's say i go here i
gave me a check i go here and you go
here yeah we get this kind of end game
getting a lot of things that you want
bishop to d5 i'll also get g5 king e5 i
mean you give me the world i'll take the
world yeah that's probably that's
probably too much that's probably enough
yeah
yeah that's uh
no that's uh yeah unfortunate no yeah
difficult end game i think if the king
was a little bit better some weaknesses
on the dark source for sure yeah i think
if the king was better you can consider
going into the end game but it's very
bad on g7 it's such a weird king i have
to say all right so we got to this
position rook to a3
is the last move well still aram is
thinking
and he played bishop to d1
all right
so
so let's say we continue staying rook to
a1 by the way instantaneously played
there's no reason to play anywhere else
right
it does finally have a threat
i guess it was actually quite important
to keep the pawn on c6 yeah i was
thinking about that while we were on
break
we rushed with the move c5 because in
some ways you prevent the king to go
from before but apparently you didn't
need to prevent them because the king
doesn't even reach b3 it doesn't reach
b3 so very important it is important to
keep the pawn on c60 restricts not only
the bishop on on d1 in many cases also
the king on d3 won't be able to have
such a clear path so let's try to create
that path with king to b2 bishop to b3
yeah and i'll give you a check and i
think this is what they've been trying
right oh they have been training okay
let's see because we actually so check
check check check check now we were
somewhere here and then whenever the
king comes to b2 you get uh okay to
check okay two chat yeah ah so
so crafty such a crafty defense all
right so he's playing bishop c2 instead
of king c2 bishop to c2
so he's trying to like zug-swung his
opponent rook a3
was played
yeah perhaps he found the right
configuration to not uh not have to
worry about anything well let's see okay
three if you go here right
yes king to d2
trying to breathe but he has
but it's okay still
let's say i go rook to a1
should be one
b1 okay so i go here i can see two
c2 that's fine
and now i go
that's so king b2 yeah that's okay and
now what now what yeah now is where i
have to think if i want to just go c4
and say you know what
it's time
c4 i don't know if it works but all
right
take it and i understand you want to go
here
but the problem is what if i give you a
check on this side looking a4 i don't
think you get back right
no but no i can even take right
this should be you know that should be a
draw i agree with you this should be
enough because there's no more c pawns
yeah i have a feeling there will be some
sort of uh
first of all one your king looks a
little bit shaky here
i mean the king you're probably going to
get out it doesn't matter yeah i could
have felt kingdom queen the instead also
but you're still taking this pawn at
something but i don't know if it's
enough even even if i take on e5 even
you should do take it yeah i i don't
know if it's enough you put a rook on
something i mean you're getting for the
rook on b3 i think
and just chill
how do you chill king g8 i don't know
i'll pick this up
yeah and then you continue chilling i
just continue chilling but how
i i understand i don't know
somewhere in the b file all right let's
say here
yeah you just keep chilling i think i
just keep killing you yeah there's no
way actually yeah there's no way
so none of this i'm seeing winning uh
you you cannot give that much material
and try to win no and they're always
going for that okay king
did arrive on b2
we're probably going to see rook to 82
check
he's trying everything look aram is
trying everything and for good reason
you know he's uh
he played a good game unfortunately
it does not seem like it was enough no
we have a lot of games christian do you
wanna you wanna just like check with the
engine and call it a day yeah
what does it say
plus one plus one usually means
that it's a draw yeah we don't see our
way to progress the engine also doesn't
seem to wait progress
probably is a draw what's happening here
this is just a lot lost yeah completely
absolutely so we're going to start
pushing the pawns at some point push
push them baby
push them baby yeah in between it really
doesn't matter
and gledura by the way this is what we
were looking at yeah that's on the
analysis side of your screen but um
where do you want to go alejandro
savion against mirin oh okay okay what's
been happening here
some craziness uh actually both players
are still
in a bit of time trouble because
smearing has 7 minutes 37 uh down to
440. so i mean actually one of the great
improvements that i've noticed in his
chest recently
has been uh falling less in time trouble
yes
against especially against strong
players he did it very well in the
american cup
where he was still falling in time
travel but not as early and not as often
and that really i think made the
difference where he was able to
calculate some key variations against
opponents uh currently though he is
falling behind on the clock quite
significantly and it's a very sharp
position because
white has uh in some ways kind of
expanded
a little bit but when you expand like
this whether your piece is going
everywhere like the move c4 the move
knight g4 with room d7 you also loosen
up a bit oh yeah you you lose it up
tactically a little bit and here for
example he's playing with knight e5
and i still i'm starting to wonder if if
black has his own resources of playing
something like rook fade and throwing
mate somehow let's see
so rook to f8 now i understand maybe
knight to g6
you will want to go to f2 right
i do not know but let's analyze it
because again let's go for it but not my
pieces right exactly not your pieces
and the thing is queen e6 probably loses
right well i just no i just taken ricket
phone as me i was looking at bishop g2
but
you don't need to be that fancy and you
you could give a check here but it
doesn't matter make a big difference
this is not a trap mate i mean you can
take but you're just that lost here
there are some checkmates coming um
knight to e5 was played rook to f8 is
the move that you're anticipating or
recommending it looks very logical right
uh knight g6 is certainly
let's say logical but not for so what if
we go here what if we take more of a
path and aram actually has drawn again
so far and he did not see a way forward
and well no way forward we didn't see it
either the computer didn't see it but
they didn't see it
and i would say that apart luckily
escapes with the draw yeah i'm not
guaranteeing that he was lost at any
point but i have a feeling
that he he suffered he suffered he
definitely suffered yeah yeah
he played bishop f2 immediately i don't
know how he missed that oh
but we didn't miss it we just weren't
analyzing it but uh i wasn't really sure
brook of fate also looked very tempting
the point is pretty obvious right you
cannot take because after it takes f2
you're going to be quite
uh damaged by this bishop takes g2
coming on the board and i don't think
there is any way you can find some
counterplay no there's no checks because
everything comes with check for black
right yeah this is just checkmate yeah
that's actually checkmate yeah trackmate
i'm going to pick up everything you put
in front of me on the a7 g1 diagonal
give me that you don't have time to play
bishop takes f2 i think you have to play
rookie one somewhere the question is
rookie one to somewhere
let's put her on f1 sure out of
curiosity
you could try to do this
are you fancy enough alejandro no
because i think bishop g2 is winning
here
for a second i thought that i can
transport teleport my queen to a e5
the bishop g2 is winning right yeah
bishop to g2 and 17 to f2 and if you go
here i take
you go here i go here let's check me
um
yeah two bishops so strong
they tend to be this bishop on eight as
you mentioned such a monster
so let's just take back
let's not get too fancy right sure
you think i take
no reason to open up the e8 rook
for free i agree
i agree
and there are no more uh
mating threats on the background which
is pretty important because queen b2 is
not available for me
you could take and queen b2 but queen of
seven is gonna make me
yeah and rook f1 played so this is
actually pretty relevant
3 minutes and 44
seconds for sam savion 5 minutes and 40
i'm counting for you yes me right
rook to f1 big big very tense game right
now incredibly tense there's a lot of
variations i really black really wants
to attack the pawn on g2 right now yes
it just doesn't have a good angle to do
so because the knight on e5 powerfully
defends the c6 square
so
bishop takes g3 now that almost feels
like a forced move you could go yeah
yeah rookie fight is the big major
alternative it's also a very logical
alternative when you think about it
because d8 is controlled just to explain
that if you take everything on f2
uh you don't have the overdate that's
very important
excuse me
uh i hear you're playing for a loss
right queen two and
you can't even take you can't even take
if you felt like going to e2 pick up the
knight um
yeah
so
so you cannot take but you don't really
want to take twice can i go knight to g6
whoa
we need three
oh that's that's a very interesting move
um
point being that if you take take take
everything i have a big threat right now
yeah of course huge actually
again the bishops
not to mention that
it's very uncomfortable to just make a
move for black
yes yes yes yes
you want to play knight g6 yeah but then
you realize that f4 actually wins
yeah
f4 and if you move the bishop f3
you're made it
yeah that's very annoying um
what do you play here though knight f3
it's a very good question and perhaps we
can
actually uh
see the whole uh the whole board right
now because yeah i do want to see his
reaction queen 3
great move i think by smirn please
quickly still a lot of things to be made
until time control wear move 34 at the
moment savion thinking i know he doesn't
want to go into this kind of
uncomfortable end game but what choice
does he have for the moment h5 is
defended and he he goes for it he knows
he doesn't have any alternative oh yeah
queen takes e3 on the board bishop takes
e3
um
maybe not rook takes f5
maybe rook to e1 right i i don't think
you want to take hold on f5 yeah just 31
h4 loses
oh my goodness
you know if you don't take on f5 h4 is a
big threat
oh this is not you might you might have
to go rook d seven two this is one not a
good sign but still h4
ah because at the end still h4 at the
i'm opening up the rook okay i see i see
you have some stuff at the end right
rook to d8 and pick up this guy
oh you're so close to losing this one
yeah g5
no but
so you go here right uh-huh
i go here bishop a5
are you happy to pay five
because the rook is defending that is so
sick
visually might only move but sufficient
right one move away
from that is so sick bishop
uh maybe here hold on
let's analyze this one
the bishop g5 you have bishop f2 i can't
i couldn't make that work
there's no win here i cannot believe
that by the way rook takes f5 is on the
board i'm surprised about that they're
going directly into this line and now
how do you defend against well let's see
what sam plays template something
not f3 yeah 903 is some of them we
mentioned
uh
actually this looks a lot nicer than the
other variation yeah it looks like you
almost lost yeah no surprise that he
goes for this one actually covering up
this uh very dominating bishop on eight
yeah
now knight three is a very good move
actually yeah
quite necessary
no more h4 no more h4 no more f i mean
you can play f4 but that's going to be
met by bishop to h4 yeah no no big deal
there uh g5 plate i think it's a much
more logical g5 yeah
you gotta go for it uh yeah
oh not only uh that you want to play h4
but also signaling that potentially you
could try to target this knife i think
this is a bishop yeah g4 f4 are like
huge threats
oh my goodness i don't know in which
order
but you look at
and this is where experience comes into
play right because right now elias
miriam is not actually calculating that
much
he's looking at the activity and the
value of his pieces yeah and he sees the
bishop on a8 ready to blast open on the
long diagonal [ __ ] pawn e3 first of all
coupling up with the light square bishop
of beautiful bishop pair in an open
position
also not allowing you to move your pawn
c5 c6 is not possible
supporting g5 and these three pawns are
three weapons right now
because i'm just going to
push h4 followed by h3 i actually i
think that's actually a big threat yeah
yeah h4 hd little threat so you have to
play h3 right no no if you play h3 i go
uh f4 first
and then g4 and i think it collapses oh
my goodness no you can't you cannot play
bishop h2 right you have to play bishop
e1 but i don't believe in it the the
spawns are they're monstrous they're
absolutely monstrous pawns um
let's try no this has to be lost right
i was thinking bishop c7 here actually
oh he did play it he played bishop c7
yeah the point is that you want to trade
the rocks he's trying to trade the rooks
with all his might
yeah
so let's say i start with g4 yes where
do you put the knight
i don't think you can go to e5 because
of bishop f4 right i think so and that
you don't have rook d5 the bishop yeah
i'm still not threatening actually i am
no you're starting bishop e5 there's no
good so perhaps you have to go king to
g1 now
but then you go bishop i know bishop c6
doesn't work so the idea being that if
you take take take rook d8 and then it
takes a8 at the end this is not a
checkmate that's why i played king to g1
let's go slowly king do you want to look
at this position
he's hanging on by a thread if he's
hanging right i mean i could even take
on g2 but
how do you feel about this end game
ah it's it's it's so difficult to say i
uh black has to be better but now the
question is how
much how much better yeah king to
g3 try to the king is
sort of passive cut off yeah it's a
little weak actually it even gets mated
sometimes yes
king of forking yeah
not not so clear to see this from
advance
uh
for il uh is there any other chance here
like do you play any other move that's
not g4 here
i don't think so right
maybe
maybe correct all right just keep the
pressure exactly why don't i go
no for her because you trade rocks
that's okay i like uk with no no i like
g4 no no but alejandro i already played
i'm completely winning
and then you just push upon it yeah
that's why i played a4 that's why i
wanted to play the move a4 um actually
that's brilliant but
as a defense against rook d8 that's
right a4
but he played g4 okay like g1
he must have seen something with 95. he
must have tactically seen something
wrong with the move now e5 that we
missed what what did we i don't know
what we missed but by the way if you
have to play knight you won
he probably didn't believe in bishop f4
king g1 which is also very likely right
yes yeah that i mean we we make it
because we don't care they're not our
pieces but he played this almost
how do you defend against h4h3 that's
also a very good and salient question
christian carrillo
because you don't even have this usual
setup with knight h6 because it actually
has zero counter play right
all right and what what if i do it
anyway
the what
h4
after knight g1 yeah yeah yeah of course
of course no no that's
now you have h3 he's actually played f4
which also makes sense oh my goodness
these pawns are the spawn is really
threatening i mean it rolls with mate
yes that's the problem it rolls with
mate isn't it
i don't see a defense okay so if you
exchange no i have three just f3 just
complete it's like it's actual mate
dismantling here yeah you cannot even
sacrifice
to give up a night yeah you cannot even
survive for a little bit no it's it's
over wow so rook theater actually just
gets made it um
look when i'm gonna
need to teach a class on the power of
the two bishops wow this one is this one
is big yeah this is a great like 1500
1400 level this is going to be the game
yeah yeah
they're so imposing right they're so
imposing it just exemplifies how
powerful these bishops are and how
powerful elias mirren is who gets up
from the board he's like f4 i'm out of
here i know i'm winning there's no
defense oh wow what a what a display
this is
one of the lowest players by far the
oldest player in the competition
f3
just four is just possible
they are so tasty wow
ilyas mirin look at him so what if i go
here
at this point i'm just trying to
sacrifice a piece and not get checkmate
right
but you can't maybe this is the best
thing i can do yeah but you resign right
right
right of course of course
f4 wow f4 devastating
are we missing any kind of trick
challenges no no right no this this has
to be this is in a book yeah this whole
game has to be in a book this was great
it was great we had an imbalanced
position and elias mirren just proving
the power of the bishops what a great
game
and against an amazing nightmare
seven who's been on fire he's been on
fire you beat wesley so with black and
spirits says hey remember me yeah
i used to be a very very good player
yeah 2700 myself as well not 100 sure
what his peak was but he was around 27
2702 27 yeah i i just looked it up he
was 2702
h3 was played by the way exactly what we
were
anticipating um
and um
yeah if i go f3 that doesn't change much
hey this mirroring was 2700 when sam
savion was six months old
yeah yeah that's that's the way it is
that's how life works
um
h3 we expect the move f3
that probably just finishes the game
he's looking at it
this was by the way 40th move
yep he's
going for it f3 yeah i don't know
hesitation no need for hesitation here
we might see a resignation right i think
we will
it is a piece
it's a piece in the worst time to do so
when black gets the extra
yeah 30 minutes because this is 40.
yeah we're going to get the king to h2
and realization starts to set in and you
just can't there's nothing you can do
here no just a4 defend the pawn depend
upon i mean the rest is trivial it's
just trivial yeah yeah yeah wow what a
display of
amazing chess by ilya smearing now
this one somehow is still not over but
look at these parts
between beer and gledura i think yeah
you think they're going somewhere
yeah
they definitely have a date
they definitely have a date with the
eighth rank all right
this one we expect white to win quite
handily and let's move on to the b group
and see if anything else is happening in
the game of the round and by the way
we've had amazing games today yeah
somebody asked us content somebody asked
us when this game became lost for uh
we have a lot of games so we're gonna
like yeah we will get there i'll cheat i
just want to know when it became like
completely hopeless sure uh the position
that we started with was actually equal
the one we we um all the way to 95.
otherwise to 95. yeah this was actually
considered equal
uh c4 was not great it didn't really
like that but rook d7 was actually a big
mistake
such a natural move yeah it was a little
too aggressive and after h5
uh 95 rookie f8 was stronger but bishop
f2 is okay rook f1 queen e3 is good
taste takes takes takes and here you
have to go h4
h4 only move to kind of survive and the
idea is
similar to what we saw in other
variations that the knight is not
exactly hiding no more g3 though yeah
genome g5 and that's the main point yeah
after knight f3 g5 it just collapses
there's nothing to do
and it's an easy move to miss this g5
it's not an easy move to miss per se but
it's an easy move to underestimate yes
yeah yes yes yes that's a
salient point um guys it's just that and
they're going straight into that
variation yeah no hope here for sam all
right except
very exciting stuff all right let's go
to group b because we haven't really uh
touched it too much yes
what is happening in
versus zoo
well it's a two result game oh this has
to be a very soon a one result game but
it does feel like it's a one result game
yeah
no i i feel this is winning it has to be
i i am like it's funny that you
mentioned the sadie uh fischer game
earlier we're getting exactly the same
structures yeah we're getting pretty
much the same structure yeah uh the
knight is dominant over the bishop
bishop is trash
i am basically
if i can attack f3 you resign yes if
there is an angle of attack on f3 it's
it's game over the thing it's not so
easy
oh yeah there you found it how do i get
there
all right so
and the thing is the king has to stop
miking the black king from penetrating
via a5 a4 if i get the king on a4 again
um so knight to c4 king here
unfortunately you are defending d2 but
now you have to defend a5 as well and my
arrows they are suffering
yeah they might need a little finagling
but i have a feeling that the same game
is hopeless for white it does look like
it even with the
equal material this is i mean the bishop
is just way too mad too bad he has no
targets on the board he's going for it
knight d6 was played yeah this looks
hopeless for white
yeah jj having an amazing tournament
really yeah jj is uh well he's no longer
your student he's finally free to
express himself alejandro he's not aware
that i'm going to yell at him after the
game
oh knight to d6 um
and by the way
he is a very promising uh young player
but also has an incredible future ahead
of himself he's going to be a phd
student yeah at the uc san diego uc san
diego in uh
bioengineering actually which is wow
extremely cool
no
lips and bounds in terms of his chest
improvement but also keeping up with his
academic prowess
and with this is there on the screen uh
as expected yes glendora did resign
again
yeah yeah we are having a great
tournament here on plus one
and
we currently have let's go for the games
that are remaining yes let's see what's
happening in a cheka versus
because this one is petering out into
what definitely a better position for
black the question is is it enough
you mean with like rook c3 right not
even
but rook to c3 is definitely a very
important question
um what if i take take
e3 e3 actually a3 is possible because on
b6 i think you're going to be h4 yeah
yeah you know if you go king g2
you cannot take because right now you're
actually uh promoting with a check so i
have to go to g2 so you do go to g2 or
h2 or whatever
maybe not whatever yeah
uh okay i go h3 i think h3 is better
another check yes
king g3 no but then e2 and then you
probably check yeah yeah yeah you get
this typical
yeah i agree with the thief
you promote one queen to get the kick on
the first house b6 was hasty we should
have stopped your part um and by the way
none of this will happen because um he
did indeed go for your initial
recommendation rook to c3 rook takes f5
takes b3 and rook to f4
uh
i'm a little surprised about this
sequence but
uh takes take stroke before k3 i assume
is a draw it's actually not so easy to
win it with g it is easy to win with g
and h but it takes a while that's what i
was trying to say at what point like if
you just remove the a pawn
like you take on f3 oh i don't care i
don't trade the rooks
right
and you remove the ap and you remove the
airplane it's a very easy it's a very
easy technical one but it's not an
immediate one
this actually once i've saved this
against an international master i'm
sorry what without the a pawn um
how did you imagine it in a place
tournament okay
tournament and i think i played for like
80 moves and at some point i was like
look it has to be a draw draw
and he accepted
i was like okay
let's move on he just tried for 80 moves
he saw that he couldn't get through and
uh but i decided to make a draw
all right so what do we have this is the
end game that we have this is the end
game that we currently have this one
between chaka and haru the union two
players that are struggling and at this
event uh the game between zuzon ciao
versus alimorandi we do think that that
one will probably be a win
for the young player from turkey ali
marandi and one game that we haven't
looked at is this one between
antipov and christopher ewing the big
group once again christopher you does
have an extra pawn nevertheless the
material is quite limited also it does
feel like the night is almost trapped
nevertheless uh still has a couple of
moves to go nevertheless
we do have
um
a big player right now with us in the
studio beer welcome to st louis welcome
to the studio first time here in st
louis yes yes i've never played in
america before how does it feel to play
against these strong players it's great
it's great i love this kind of
tournament excellent now speak to me
about this game against benjamin gledura
quite a peer he's only a few years older
than you how do you approach this game
i'm just like like any other game i
think it was a very important game for
me because i had a couple of
disappointing games before this game so
it was very nice which one which ones
were you um
disappointing i lost around before this
and also i made a draw against abby
manuel misha from uh winning possession
oh that that position when you had queen
to b4 at that point yes
uh take us through this game yes all
right
give us the critical moments let's say
e3 yes yes
i think we were both not really prepared
for this line actually so we used some
time here too but it's all very normal i
had a game
like this before already normal stuff a6
castle b5 bishop to a2 yeah and after
queenie 2 i think he was considering if
he should go for
the most critical line was taken d4 here
one
d1 b4 this is a very big mainline yeah
yeah were you prepared without
disclosure
not really for this game but i think we
both didn't really remember this line so
so he decided not to go for it and he
played the move bishop to e7 yeah
followed up with rook to d1
yeah i think i got a pleasant position
here i have some development advantage
now you just have those type of
symmetrical positions in which white
just has the better placed pieces yeah
exactly i'm a bit a bit quicker than him
one to ten piece ahead yeah so i think
the
what i should try to do is get this
bishop b194 very quickly and then it can
be
be dangerous for him so what's the point
of that you have to eliminate this
defender this is not an f6 and then his
king is a bit vulnerable and the c file
opens up for me
nice
so that's what we were both kind of
trying he was trying to avoid it and i
was trying to get an idea for him a man
with a plan in this one for sure bishop
to b1 it's always good to have
uh a plan rook takes d1 queen takes do
you want to look to c8 knight to g yeah
sure maybe i should have played uh 94
immediately but i thought for some
reason knight g5 was even more exciting
perhaps something like 28 28 yeah and i
wasn't sure maybe it's not so much yeah
i don't know queen to see maybe maybe he
can put that somewhere or night i don't
know if it works something like night
even knight before yeah
yeah yeah that's probably
problematic right yeah uh cool so you
play this move knight to g5 but now it's
suddenly very
very complicated okay
and now yeah
maybe queen of three is not the best
mirror
because i think after queen f3 he can
play knight d4
this is the movie you were worried about
i'm not sure what happens here maybe i
have to go back is what i thought and
it's
so the idea being that if you take this
take the knight e to check 92 and take
if i take it then you're going to get
checkmated
regardless of whether you take with the
knight or the bishop and i think also
after knight d4 bishop h7 doesn't really
work it was kind of like in the game but
here it's not
great
so 94 maybe maybe 94 works i thought so
what to do right now
you have to drop back with the queen
yeah and then he can decide if he wants
to go back and i can make another move
because he wants to play another fighter
yeah but knight f5 it should be a slight
improvement for him i think but this is
so queen takes b792 and you actually
have a very nice trick
i don't see three hangs at the end right
yeah quite unfortunate and everything
seems to be protected for black okay
knight to d4 and he missed this yeah but
the queen d2 could you potentially go
queen to h3 um i think a knight and go
go a bit crazy and see
you take and then
maybe i have some checkmating
patterns around here
and we should be
for yeah it doesn't it doesn't really
work doesn't seem to be working i think
rook takes c3 is coming yeah yeah very
shaky yeah you'll get checkmated first
or first right probably yeah cool so you
play he played this move queen to d2 and
it does seem like yeah this was very
telling because but maybe he
i think bishop h7 is a good move i
didn't really find something for you no
that this seems to be the right way
i think you can play rook g8 but i think
it's
it's not great i can make some move like
knight f4 maybe
yeah
and knight to f8 is met with queen to h5
and yeah very nice checkmate
and you can never open up
the long diagonal because some
lightweight four is going to come um
yeah devastating consequences
i have three points and then attack
still so i think he was counting on this
bishop f6 idea yeah to stay active and
try to win the piece back yeah and then
we got to this point
quite visual uh in fact
with this opportunity for him to
potentially continue with checks
but then you have this idea with knight
left yes exactly exactly and uh you both
saw it you guys went into this queen to
e6 but this is yourself yeah i think it
was basically forced after 95 to get to
this position yeah but yeah it looks
like it should be winning for right and
by the way we do have on the screen at
the end of the game between smearing and
sam savion smearing did indeed win
that game jonas congratulations a huge
victory for you who do you have tomorrow
thank you
um
i'm playing against operon
with black yes big game against
operating we'll let you go back home get
ready for that get your energy levels up
and we'll see you tomorrow yes thank you
what an impressive young man and uh what
a victory for him against benjamin
gledura and actually that
finalized group a for today all the
results are in and let's take a look at
the standings right now in group a we
have still yu yang he leading the pack
with four points out of uh seven tied
for second position abhimanyu mishra
benjamin glendora and jonas bier who's
uh joining uh the pack tied for second
position with three and a half points a
piece in fifth position around hercobian
and sam savion gregory apparent
ilyasmirin and nico t other with two and
a half
group when you think about it indeed in
last place you're on minus one yeah yeah
incredible
i mean it just goes to show
that these players in terms of strength
and caliber are very close to each other
yeah absolutely uh no no big outliners
and this is what is expected at this
round robins yeah so very quickly what's
going on in group b
i see the action has slowed down a
little bit well you've been uh on the
on the sidelines alejandro and you've
been researching the games what uh
caught your eye the antipov game
actually was very interesting uh because
i think the lmr on the game is going
i i i assume it's just lost it has to be
there has to be lost this has to be lost
there's no way
knight to b2 followed by knight d3 i
mean i think at this point you're like
choosing which way to win knight a39 c2
also looks like it should win somehow
yeah um
so yeah
jj in a great position uh the antibuff
game wasn't so sure uh black is up a
pawn
but his uh his knight's getting
strangely stranded um
[Music]
so it might just be a draw
i don't know it's hard to say for me
yeah no i mean it does look like the
material is quite limited
nevertheless
christopher is still pressing right
still pressing that must be
quite disappointing for uh misha antipov
to have to defend this type of positions
with the white pieces but i have to say
once again we see how compact the field
is and how close these players are
of each other in terms of strength
now what other games do we have we do
have this game between cheka and haruti
union and we weren't sure we actually
got to the position that we discussed uh
this end game and we mentioned that
without a pawn on the a file this is a
easy victory for the black side the two
pawns nevertheless with the a pawn it
might become a little bit tricky because
the rook is most likely going to go
behind the pawn and then the question is
how are you going to make any progress
if you do have to place the rook in
front of the pawn but while we get ready
to analyze this end game we do have a
special guest another victor of today's
round elias miriam
congratulations welcome to the show oh
and now my my on my usual place more or
less commentator commentator excellent
excellent a peer commentator here in the
studio now um this is your first victory
big event for you first time in st louis
third one
third time yeah third time i played
already such a tournament
a couple of years ago
and minus one i lost in last round
and also i was commenting online uh
tournament i guess in
in
bucharest grand prix so second time as a
player certain time as a player and
commentators third player third time as
a person excellent excellent now take us
through uh today's round the big game
against sam savion one of the favorites
of this event with the black pieces how
did you approach this game yeah it was
first of all after such a
miserable
let's say start
no i was quite relaxed but it was
interesting to me from the beginning to
play with sam because
we played already one very interesting
game which i included in my book on
sicilian which i beat basically in the
no not in the same line but it also was
khan
in sicilian and it was clear for me that
he wanted to he would like to take
revenge of course
[Music]
no okay and also in this tournament i
lost without any fight to
union ghee in this in this line just
i don't know why i
played terrible today
i decided to play more mode the slide
not b6 which i played but bishop b7 it's
more positional
castle i decided to
to develop some pieces at least why not
custom knight c6 yeah why not knight
takes e6 bishop c6 rookie one its main
move i guess and 97 is quite a rare move
i i think
97 rare move did you feel like uh this
surprised sam i think yes i think he
didn't know it uh
i also little i i knew it just a bit i
analyzed just a bit before the game
maybe a couple of five minutes maybe
yeah but 97 it looks logical you know i
i don't i don't uh
develop my bishop yet i don't know where
i would develop it but knight goes to g6
and after i will decide whether i put my
bishop on from f8
d6 c5 maybe 7 maybe before in some cases
who knows yeah so he played queen h5 it
looks like a very logical move between
h5 knight g6 a4 a4 i'm not sure
no okay before 95 i didn't like but it
simply takes so this was probably his
idea no of course it was his idea and i
didn't like to that my
queen side is because he probably cannot
take because no no this is just
this is just very beautiful game over
yeah yeah this is game over
that's why i just take on took on a4 it
looks for me most
most natural natural and bishop d6 is
also quite natural
okay he can play e5 here
but after the five i was thinking maybe
queen a5 i have more
maybe
attacking the rook attacking the pawn on
e5
who knows it was interesting
okay e5 he didn't play he played knight
c5 but it's clear that after knight c5
blake has no problems whatsoever
i made castle i could play something
else but castle i decided and he played
bishop d2
i played 95 looks okay also not the only
move so no problems
yeah maybe maybe queen b6 maybe
something else yeah and the problem is
even if it goes bishop basically i can
take simply
why not yeah and i want to play now
bishop i don't know what i want
no yeah this cannot be good for him no
it looks a little bit awkward let's say
yeah so he played bishop d2 bishop d2
and i played 95 also not only move of
course but reasonable bishop's history
i i i wanted to play f6 first uh not
take on d3 but after i decided to take
on d3 pick up the two bishops yeah
maybe a little bit overestimated my
position here i saw that i have maybe
advantage but
but in fact i guess position is more or
less balanced after f5 f3 he played f3 i
underestimated his move
because he holds together everything and
i'm not better i understand
i understood this
okay i played what i played
first definitely
yeah bishop said i definitely have no
problems here yeah but also he is quite
centralized and his pieces quite uh
coordinated quite well so
i don't think he he also has a problem
yeah sincerely speaking he played a5
a5
yeah
and i thought he would he would repeated
move bishop b7
because objectively speaking it was
maybe best decision for him
at least from practical point of view i
don't know i don't know what computer
computer says that bishop
i think i think as well that bishop's
history she should go for a draw but he
decided to look for some practical
chances against old men you know
and
and but i am not that old yet
so i played what i played take take d6
very simple now experience definitely
plays in your favor no i like
championships all my life i like i love
to play with two bishops basically
and here is i guess i am slightly better
but he played correctly e5
also i underestimated because i thought
first that to open up this diagonal it's
extremely dangerous but
but from other side he has counter play
so
rook f5 i guess correct d take bishop b7
correct rook d1 i think queen b6 is also
correct in my opinion mm-hmm yeah and i
played here uh what i played this whole
sequence seems to be quite precise from
both sides yeah bishop c5 would move
perhaps here we have already in some
time trouble uh bishop c5 i just
activated my bishop don't let him know
three
sephora c4 and this is bishop eight
probably
most exact move yes i just put my bishop
out of way
yes just defend it yeah just to get
it's not easy for him i mean he cannot
attack it harass it let's see yes so
bishop eight in my opinion black is
better here
maybe much better at least from a
practical perspective
yeah definitely against computer i
wouldn't win right i have no doubt about
that but against human it looks really
frightening uh to play white i would be
frightening because bishops are like
monsters absolutely and okay rook on d7
is active but all my piece is also not
bad but it does feel like actually a
rook to d7 might be quite the biggest
yeah
okay but in time trouble he wanted to
make some extra more active moves of
course and i also underst i also
evaluated this because bishop of tuthi
clearly missed in my opinion
am i looking at this in my opinion we
were thinking yeah
also you know i didn't know what to play
with it also looks very good yeah i i
don't know why i played bishop of two
maybe rook of fate would be even
stronger i'm i wouldn't be surprised
since my shift still maintains an
advantage yeah i mean rook of fate i i
probably was afraid of something like
bishop d3 or united states
but maybe something like i don't know
what
maybe something would work maybe bishop
of two here i don't know
yeah but it's you know in in time
troubles i was afraid little bit too
miscalculate no absolutely and by the
way this is unclear whether yeah
right because no i i think
yeah the eighth yeah yeah yeah that
might be a problem yeah yeah no yeah and
wait on h5 here yeah so
uh that's why i played bishop of two
just very simple move but very active
yes at the same time
three i think good move i don't know
what computer says about when you say
good move yeah yeah queen e3 was
definitely because here it's very hard
position for white the only move
apparently
keeps him
in play is actually h4 right h4 maybe i
would not allow you to go g yeah yeah i
was thinking about j4 okay black is
better obviously yes but white is still
in the game but position is not easy
trying to survive and by the way this
move h4 is so difficult yeah because you
see f4 yeah but now he can play some uh
because rook g8 check
he can something correct you can just
like make bishop to e1
maybe yeah and then so white is still in
the game somehow somehow yeah somehow
but he played this move on knight to f3
alone
it's over yeah completely i like
demolition
not only vicious but now pounds are
helping you're enjoying the position
uh beautiful game uh extraordinary
execution towards the end now tell us
about your
game tomorrow who do you face
since
with white i faced i think youngest
youngest project yeah
have you ever faced him before no i i
never saw him before i guess he's as
well but he is quite impressive here
for his age of course but all but even
without connection with he played is
quite a good player
should be an interesting fight yeah
interesting why not i'm playing for
chess now to be interesting excellent
and we love to see that thank you very
much for joining us congratulations
thank you
and we'll see you tomorrow thanks
and uh let's take a look at the
standings in group a after this result
we still have you young yi leading the
pack with four points three and a half
points for abhimanyu beijing ladura
and sam savion tied for fifth with three
points
and gregory oppar in ilya smirin and
nicolas theodore tied for seventh
position with two and a half points a
piece
and let's take a look at the standings
in group b
as well rather live results we have
dragoon camille who drew his game quite
easily and quick against guillermo
vasquez before we came on
live on the show nico chekhov versus the
gran harutinian is still going on bichon
tipo versus christopher you still going
on
also zuzon ciao versus ali marandi
alejandra welcome back uh we're uh
approaching the end of our show final
thoughts about today's round experience
very smirn wow
what a great game that was actually
you can see the joy in his eyes when he
like goes through the game
still such a strong player still so
talented still so passionate about the
game uh it's just amazing to see this
game is going into his next book
i think so too
amazing round join us tomorrow for the
championship rounds the eighth and ninth
round coming up in the next couple of
days we will be here to call all the
action at 3 30 p.m central time here on
twitch or on youtube or on
usgs.com wherever you are watching we
will see you tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you